as you can see on the left hand side of
the board we know how to deal with log
functions that have a base of a those
are the night just nice and tidy ones
but we can deal with them with other
bases if you like we just convert of AC
and then off you go okay however
sometimes a question I like what's on
the board a question will be kind of
ambiguous and they'll just say something
like this okay or of course I'll
substitute something else instead of
just eggs they'll have a whole function
in there like 1 minus in the exit or
whatever your life okay now really
important that you know if it's get
another color show when you see log X
and no base is indicated all of the
interesting and elegant and beautiful
and simple mathematics as you can see
happens in base e this is nice and tidy
here just introduces a constant for the
sake of being curves okay that's that's
not really the point in exactly the same
way as when you were learning Pythagoras
for the first time everything was nice
and meets 3 4 5 5 12 13 all the nice
numbers okay and we could put awful
numbers but you don't learn much about
Pythagoras you just get more fun working
with decimals so therefore when you see
this you should always assume it has
base e if you see it in a test if you
see it in your textbook you should
always assume when there's no base imply
basically is what Smith indicated except
there is one exception
the one exception is mmm as I asked you
to get out a second ago on this little
guy which is so very inconvenient
because you happen to you seem quite
often right on your calculators you will
see our log button with lower face in
clyde wright and on your calculator the
base is 10 now they try to be helpful so
you can see on your calculator it says a
log like that and then right beside it
there's an ln button so you like all
clearly that one is maybe you wouldn't
know about two buttons for the same
thing nevermind the fact that you've got
two buttons for a negative sign but
anyway yeah that would be unusual
exactly a reason for that but um why did
you base 10 you can also see by the way
to indicate on your calculator that long
by itself is based on just look above
look above the button you see in yellow
it says 10 to the power R it's an
exponential base 10 which is how you
know that log buttons also has based in
now why do they do that if I just which
you know labor the point that base is
the interesting one and the reason was
because this is not a mathematically to
which you would respond what other kind
of calculator is it and the answer is a
scientific calculator right scientists
are very very interested in base 10 it
is after all the base that we use for
our entire number system and more
importantly there's this little thing
called the scientific notation which is
next 10 okay so using log base 10 is an
easy way to know what's the magnitude
because remote corresponds to that to
house so so some calculators have that I
have a double check because most of them
should not do I see your calculator very
brief enough water yeah yeah that one's
all this that's something else Oh number
base like hexadecimal binary not about
this base that's like so so just to
emphasize right base is where it's
happening your textbook means you're
there's a Trans Am you see questions are
in an exam they're generally pretty nice
and they try and take the everybody out
and then we'll write log base a of X
cumulative sees as pretty much the way
it is and I write is purely because i'm
lazy and it's faster and being lazy is a
key characteristic about the students
because tragic things as simply as
possible so um now you know now you know
what that means and where it means that
is it just too much